grab a drink and settle down because we
have the final Marvel TV series until
our corporate Disney overlords take over
everything our new corporate overlords
know yes Jessica Jones season 3 has come
to an end bringing with it the end of
the Netflix Marvel Universe so in this
episode we're gonna be taking a deep
dive into the ending its villain and how
everything came together to give us one
of the most character-driven Marvel
shows ever the season ends with Jessica
at the train station asking for a
one-way ticket to his close to Mexico as
she can get she's packed her bags and
even handed the keys of her Detective
Agency over to Malcolm ironically enough
if you go back to episode 1 this is what
Malcolm wanted all along to start his
own p.i firm well with the experience
you get here along with my eventual
recommendation you'll be able to launch
your own PR firm Jessica tells us
through narration that the cost of being
a hero is too much stating what's it
gonna take to make it feel right the
answer is
too much the events of this season have
taken their toll on her first having to
fight off the serial killer Gregory
Salinger who we'll get to in a bit only
to find out the only family she has left
in the world her sister Patricia is the
real villain of the season with her
behind bars she decides to leave
everything behind and skirt her
responsibilities as a bona fide hero
right before she accepts the ticket
however she's haunted by the voice of
killgrave the villain from season one
notice also the purple glow purple being
heavily associated with kilgrave's
character it's at this point that
Jessica leaves the ticket behind and
decides to stay in New York ready to
tackle whatever case comes her way she
has completed her character arc of
accepting herself as a hero and this arc
is contrasted with Trish who at the end
accepts herself as the villain Trish
starts the season having been given
superhuman powers in season two she can
now be the hero Jessica never fully
embraced we see her training listening
to the police radio and even go into a
costume shop to try on new superhero
looks even turning down a costume that
looks a lot like Hellcat the character
she's based on for Trish she can finally
make a difference rather than wasting
her time hulking clothing on her
Shopping Network show but early on in
the season Trish's methods are shown to
be in direct contrast to Jessica's you
know you do it your way I'm gonna do in
episode 5 Trish and Jessica argue about
how they should get Salinger to confess
Trish wants to beat the crap out of him
letting her emotions get the best of her
well jessica is more practical if
they're gonna lock Salinger up they're
gonna need proof evidence things need to
be done a proper way
it's these differing methods that will
eventually lead Trish to go full villain
never go full villain
whereas Jessica hates to be in the
spotlight Trish embraces it I mean could
you expect anything less than a former
child star she even calls upon a
photographer to take pictures of her as
the masked vigilante she wants people to
know she's fighting the bad guys but
this all changes at the end of episode 8
when Salinger kills Trish's mother door
fueled by rage Trish breaks into
Salinger's apartment assaulting two
innocent police officers in the process
instead of bringing Salinger into
custody she takes justice into her own
hands about to kill him until she's
stopped by Jessica from here she
secretly teams up with Eric and first
accidentally kills the crooked cop
nussbaumer then brutally murders a
builder who she believed responsible for
14 fire related deaths deaths he claims
were accidental she takes justice into
her own hands without giving this guy a
fair trial or hearing his side of the
story what's worse is that this murder
has more to do with her taking out her
rage for Salinger than it has to do with
justice at all this is shown when the
camera switches to her beating up
Salinger as if she's fantasizing about
beating him up when Eric arrives he's
shocked at what she's done Eric who has
the ability to feel if others are good
or bad now feels that Trish has turned
to the dark side and instead of
contemplating what she's just done this
is what she says is the world better
I can make it better she essentially
doubles down obsessed with making things
better and she believes she can make the
world better by killing the person she
wants to most Salinger which is exactly
what she does at the end of the episode
while in custody Trish brutally murders
Salinger who would have spent the rest
of his life locked away but this isn't
before she asked him what he needed to
see in her mother the death of Salinger
at the hands of Trish is the final straw
that shows Jessica Trish's true nature
and that ultimately she must be stopped
Gregory Salinger who is portrayed as the
main villain throughout the season is an
interesting case because he doesn't rely
on super powers to fight Jessica Jones
he uses his smarts using Jessica's moral
compass against her Jessica knows that
she can walk right into his apartment
and kill him but part of what makes
Jessica a hero is her moral compass
she's a private eye she believes in
evidence the criminal justice system and
bringing down the bad guys the right way
because Salinger is so smart and covers
his tracks so well putting him behind
bars is much more difficult she'll need
to rely not on her super strength to
bring him down but plain old detective
work in this way Salinger and Jones are
an equal match even though she can kick
the crap out of him in wrestling she'll
need to outsmart and outwit this dude
who holds four degrees and can kill
without leaving a trace but why does
Salinger kill he isn't evil just for the
sake of being evil his motivations are
driven by his upbringing and psychology
in episode six when he has Eric tied up
we get a little more insight into his
character as a child his older brother
Donny got all the love and affection
from his father no matter what Greg did
his brother was always the favorite when
Donny died in a tragic tractor accident
Gregory thought he would then become the
favorite but instead his father said he
should have been the one to die it's
this event that created Salinger's
disdain for people who are privileged
entitled and fake you never worked hard
I made any effort to improve it was
handed to you
Salinger's hate for supers like Eric and
Jessica now becomes clear Eric and
Jessica didn't have to work for their
powers they just got them just like how
Donny didn't have to work for his
father's love he just got it this
jealousy fuels Salinger to become better
work harder hence the four degrees even
when Jessica visits the de Silva family
the mother and father of Nathan who was
Greg's first kill way back in high
school they tell Jessica that wrestling
- Nathan came very easy he was born with
a talent for it which resulted in Greg
who worked hard at it still being beaten
every time this jealousy kept growing in
Greg until he eventually killed his
friend and buried him under the gazebo I
guess an apt analogy would be the film
Amadeus where the composer Salieri who
devoted his entire life to music is
outperformed by Mozart who was born with
an innate gift for musical composition
Salinger also takes photos of his
victims the moment they see the truth in
themselves he wants his victims to know
the lie they've been telling themselves
when he has Jessica tied up for example
he wants her to admit that she's always
deep down wanted to be a hero her rock
garb look is her costume her detective
agency a lazy cliche front to help
others but more importantly if she's not
a hero then the death of her parents
would have been for nothing
you believed they were sacrificed in
exchange for your gifts that they died
so that you could save the world she was
given these powers what if she did
nothing with them it would be a waste
and her parents would have died for
nothing my mother thought there was
nothing more precious in the world than
talent and nothing more shameful than
wasting it and it's this idea of what
makes a hero which is at the core of the
season in Episode one Jessica states
I hate heroism at almost every turn
Jessica does her best to distance
herself from the word it's the lie she
tells herself a hero is strong a hero is
invulnerable a hero
as a goddamn spleen Trish needed a hero
she got me and you're the quintessential
hero not even close
being a hero is not just about being
strong it's about making tough decisions
and that's exactly what Jessica does
when she takes down her own sister the
newspaper even proclaiming her a bona
fide hero this decision was helped by
the appearance of Luke Cage at the
beginning of the final episode this
thing you got to do it's hard he knows
he had to put away his own brother it
was tough and still haunts him but it's
what had to be done running away from it
won't solve her problems but facing them
head-on just might which is why she
turns away at the end of the episode
ready to start a new chapter of her life
to other characters who start new
chapters at the end are Jerry Hogarth
and Keith Jerry who he learned is dying
from ALS spends much of the season
trying to keep her firm afloat while
simultaneously masterminding plans to
win back her true love and it's Jerry's
methods of going about getting KITT back
that make her a villain in her own right
she ends up exposing Kitts husband Peter
for his charity embezzlement scam which
results in him killing himself it's
Jerry's selfish desire for KITT that
drives her to do bad things in the end
however Jerry actually sacrifices
herself taking herself prisoner under
Trish
so that Keith can be free but even that
gesture isn't good enough for KITT you
did what you did because we were both in
a dangerous insane situation that you
created yes Jerry did sacrifice herself
for Keith but that never would have
happened if Jerry didn't make a
multitude of immoral decisions she
blackmailed Peter represented serial
killer Greg Salinger and had Malcolm
engage in criminal behavior to keep her
guilty clients out of jail Jerry
deserves what she got and check out this
savage takedown by kif
I know you don't want to tell him
are you going to there's also Malcolm
who I won't talk to in great detail as
his Ark doesn't really influence the
ending of the series but he ends up
ruining his whole relationship with
zaiah and kind of got what he deserved -
he did Jerry's dirty work like putting a
known drunk back behind the wheel he
hooks up with a prostitute and this loss
of moral integrity should have
consequences so I'm all for Zale leaving
him I just wonder with Jessica deciding
to stay in New York if she'll be wanting
those keys back thanks everyone for
watching if you liked this video make
sure to LIKE and subscribe I have more
videos on the way so you'll want to stay
tuned you can also follow me on twitter
at think story whitey and until next
time remember daddy loves you very much